you have to believe in what you're
selling whatever product or service it
is with all your heart that it's going
to help people or you're not going to be
successful one of my readers recently
wrote in her name was Theresa and she's
having a lot of problems with affiliate
programs she's invested into a number of
different affiliate programs it's not
working she's losing money you know they
promised her get-rich-quick schemes and
it's not working teresa sorry to hear
that story you know it really sucks it
sucks and a lot of entrepreneurs can
drive din to the same thing with a lot
of affiliate programs or network
marketing programs the main reason why
these things fail aside from the product
not being you know great is that the
people selling it ie you have no
personal commitment or attachment to
what you're selling you have to believe
in what you're selling if you're
starting the business affiliate or
otherwise just trying to make a lot of
money it's really going to happen you
have to promote the products and
services that you use and then tell a
story around it and how helpful it is
for you if you look at the things that I
talked about if you look at the programs
that I promote most of them I don't get
paid anything for but I use all of them
i only share stories about the tools
that i'm actually using and putting the
use either my personal life or my
business and that makes it credible and
it makes it authentic i can speak to
whatever product or service out of a
genuine love for what I'm selling or
promoting but also I know it's going to
help people
I get approached by companies all the
time they see my audience they see the
connections that I have on YouTube and
Twitter and all all the social media and
they say Ivan we want you to promote our
product I got approached last week by to
brand name clients wanted me to promote
their products and I've never used what
they're selling and I couldn't find a
use for it for my business and so I told
them I can't I can't do this it's great
money but you're building a relationship
with your clients right and you also
want to feel good about what you're
doing so I said no you want to only
promote the product and services that
you feel passionately about it will not
only bring more money to you but you'll
feel better about what you're doing
you'll you'll like what you're doing and
that's half the battle because if you
don't enjoy what you're doing you're not
going to last running the business is
hard you're going to go through so many
ups and downs and a lot of downs so she
at the beginning that only the love for
what you're doing will push you through
affiliate programs network marketing can
work but it starts with you really using
whatever program that you're selling and
find an immense value in it when you
start promoting that you want to tell
your story show people how you're using
a product and how it's really helping
you if you don't have a personal
attachment to that product or service
leave it go find something else find a
different program or product to promote
something that you care about that you
deeply feel other people need to know
about this because it's going to change
their lives like it's changed mine you
have to have that passionate story and
if you have that passion of story you
believe in what you're selling so much
and you know what's going to help people
that'll catch people will want to be
like you they'll want to get the same
result that you got
so maybe I'm not answering the question
as you asked it I don't know what the
next affiliate program is that you
should join I can't recommend one you've
got to find something that you love
maybe this isn't you make maybe it's
something you make yourself or something
promoted on behalf of somebody else but
you've got to love it you've got to use
it you got to know that by promoting
that you're helping people tell your
story that'll make all the difference in
the world good luck for those of you
watching if you believe in this message
if you think it's true that you gotta
love what you're promoting please give
this video a thumbs up it makes me want
to do more of these for you I love doing
the videos for you guys and if you have
a comment or question about your own
business I'd love to try to help answer
it for you give my feedback just leave
it in the comments section below thank
you and I'll see you soon
you